Javier is calibrating sophisticated
medical imaging equipment.
The manual reports that the tangent
of a particular angle is one.
So that's saying that the tangent
and let's say that that particular angle
is theta is equal to one.
What should Javier do to find the angle?
And I encourage you to pause this video
and look at these choices
and think about which of these
should he do to find the angle?
So let's look through each of them.
So the first one...
well, actually, instead
of looking at the choices,
let's think about what we would do
to find the angle.
So they're saying that the tangent of
some angle is equal to one.
Well one thing that you
might want to do is say
okay, if we take the inverse tangent,
if we take the inverse tangent,
of the tangent of theta,
so if we take the inverse tangent
of both sides of this,
we of course would get
the inverse tangent of
the tangent of theta.
If the domain over here is
restricted appropriately,
is just going to be equal to theta,
so we could say the theta
is going to be the inverse tangent of one.
So it might be tempting to just
pick this one right over here.
Type inverse tangent of
one into his calculator.
So maybe this looks like the best choice.
But remember,
I said if we restrict the
domain right over here.
if we restrict the
possible values of tangent,
of theta here appropriately,
then this is going to simplify to this.
But there is a scenario
where this does not happen.
And that's if we pick
thetas that are outside
of the range of the
inverse tangent function.
What do I mean by that?
Well it's really just based on the idea
that there are multiple
angles that have...
or multiple angles whose tangent is one.
And let me draw that here
with a unit circle here.
So we draw a unit circle,
so that's my x axis,
that's my y axis,
let me draw my unit circle here.
Actually you probably don't even
have to draw the unit circle,
because the tangent is really much more
about the slope of the ray
created by the angle,
than where it intersects the unit circle
as would be the case with sine and cosine.
So if you have..
so you could have this
angle right over here.
So let's say this is a candidate theta,
where the tangent of this theta is
the slope of this line,
and this terminal angle,
the terminal ray, you could say
of the angle.
The other side, the initial ray,
is along the positive x axis.
And so you could say,
okay the tangent of this theta,
the tangent of this theta is one.
Because the slope of this line is one.
Let me scroll over a little bit.
Well, so let me write it this way.
So tangent theta is equal to one.
But I can construct another theta
whose tangent is equal to one
by going all the way over here
and essentially going in
the opposite direction
but the slope of this line,
so let's call this theta two,
tangent of theta two is also
going to be equal to one.
And of course you could go another
pi radiance and go back
to the original angle,
but that's functionally the same angle
in terms of where it is relative
to the positive x axis,
or what direction it points into,
but this one is fundamentally
a different angle.
So we do not know,
we do not have enough information
just given what we've been told
to know exactly
which theta we're talking about,
whether we're talking
about this orange theta
or this mauve theta.
So I would say the get more information,
there are multiple angles
which fit this description.